The Joker's lured us this is the blight
of the island he grew up on the other
side of this barrier today it's
off-limits this is for OSHA the tourist
center of the city of Famagusta once
tourism flourished here making the area
the richest in Cyprus until the Turkish
military landed on the island ten
dagestan Meadows disposition part of
Famagusta has been fenced off for 40
years since the summer of 1974 when we
fled from here I was seven years old we
lost everything
hotels everything we owned we Greeks
left everything behind
Isaiah the myth today Famagusta belongs
to the turkish part of Cyprus
Greeks no longer live here Jurgis
Lourdes wants to change that he and
other Greeks have joined with Turks in a
citizen's initiative that's working to
bring Bharata back to life once we open
up the bar OSHA - and return its legal
owners we know that there will be many
business opportunities this means that
there will be many opportunities for the
people to find jobs about for the
Turkish support and the for the Greek
support if there's a solution for virosa
than this one for the entire island we
just realized that the negotiation
process is heading nowhere with the
leaders sitting at the negotiation table
without involving two communities the
civil society groups and the communities
so we decided to take the initiative and
to make a sort of public opinion change
in the region the northern part of the
island is still controlled by the Turks
Joris lordose remembers when Turks and
Greeks both lived scattered around the
island today he has to cross a border
that separates the Greeks and Turks only
in the past eleven years have both
groups been able to cross over freely
yoga slow those lives in the South in
the Greek part near the city of Larnaca
the credit crisis has forced many
businesses to close and the local
economy isn't deep recession with no
relief in sight for the time being
reunification would open up economic
opportunities most of all in the
construction sector there's a lot to do
there but there would also be new
opportunities for trade with Turkey and
it would give Cyprus the stability of
needs for its role as a hub in the
region methodologies tourism plays an
important role there yoga centers family
built a new life a few kilometers south
of Famagusta they got a fresh start in
the 1970s with this hotel it's given
them enough financial stability that
they don't really need their old hotels
in the Turkish part that's not what it's
really about for us Turkish Cypriot
economy to finally have access to the
European Union which will offer it a lot
of possibilities and would allow that
part of the island to finally be able to
get all the supplies that with no
problems petty the border could
disappear in just a few years
at least that's what the members of the
citizens initiative belief they've been
carrying out heavily symbolic actions
aimed at overcoming the division
step-by-step as of late Greeks are
allowed to once again visit the church
in the Turkish part it's a start